The Last Days of Ptolemy Grey
is the story of a man
who lives in delusions.
-What's wrong with you?
-I'm so sorry.
He's in his mid-90s.
He's right there at the precipice
of full-out dementia.
-A car--
-Hey!
He's far in the back of his own mind.
He needs help.
Seem like I can't remember
nothing no more.
They go to a doctor
who has this miracle drug.
After the doses are administered,
Mr. Grey will remember everything
that he has ever known.
The doctor has a medicine
that will bring him back to consciousness
for maybe a month.
This is an opportunity
to reclaim parts of his life
that he's been searching for.
Oo! I’m goin’ home!
He takes the medicine.
He regains his memory.
And in a very slender window of time,
he tries to do all the things
in his life that he failed at.
He wants to fix his relationships
and solve a riddle in his mind,
and it drives the story.
What is he trying to do?
And why does he need to do it so badly?
Come on in.
Sensia?
She gone, boy.
This is a man struggling
to reclaim his life through his memories.
We have our present-day story,
we have flashbacks to 1930s Mississippi,
and we have '70s sequences.
And it was really, really amazing to see
all of these things come to life.
It's almost time.
Best be getting home.
Me and Walter been trying
to do this project for like ten years.
It's a universal thing.
When you have a loved one
that doesn't know who you are anymore,
it's like the most heartbreaking thing
in the world.
Sam has gone to a place
that he hasn't usually gone.
Sam is so perfect for this role
because it needs an actor
of a certain maturity
and a certain genius.
What's going to be really compelling
for his fans and for the audience
is to see him in a role
where he is vulnerable,
much older, very different
from anything we've ever seen him do.
It's a fanciful story of
what someone would do
if they had an opportunity to right the wrongs
of a life that they've lived.
We carry such shame for the things
that we've done in our past,
and at the end of the day,
you got one life to live.
So what are you going to do with it
while you're here?
There are times when you get it right.
We had the time, and the space,
to get this right.